in a world where digital Footprints are
traced censorship looms and cyber
threats lurk in the shadows the need for
a shielded connection has never been
more crucial that's your VPN swoop in
like digital superheroes whisking your
way into a realm of secure browsing
Anonymous identities and unrestricted
access to the vast vendors of the web
welcome back tech Enthusiast and curious
minds today we are diving into the
mysterious realm of vpns but how exactly
does this technological Marvel operate
how does it cloak your online activities
and your true location feeling curious
well today we will demystify the inner
workings of vpns and help you with the
knowledge picture this you are stripping
your favorite beverage at a local cafe
enjoying the convenience of public Wi-Fi
little do you know lurking nearby could
be cyber criminals itching to snatch
your sensitive information but fret note
with a VPN by your side your connection
transforms into a impregnable Fortress
encrypting your data and shielding it
from prying eyes so grab your
metaphorical passports faster your
virtual seat belts and join me on this
captivating Expedition through the inner
workings of VPN technology without
further Ado let the quest to unveil the
wonders of vpns begin before we begin if
you are someone who is interested in
building a career in cyber security by
graduating from the best universities or
a professional who elicits to switch
careers with cyber security by learning
from the experts then try giving a short
to Simply learn postgraduate program in
cyber security with modules from MIT
schwarzman College of Engineering the
course link is mentioned in the
description box that will navigate you
to the course page where you can find a
complete overview of the program being
offered if these are the types of videos
you would like to watch then hit the
Subscribe button like and press the Bell
icon to never miss on further content
now let's get started here we'll start
with what is a VPN then we'll see how
does a VPN work and then we will see the
types of vpns and then see the
advantages of VPN and then explore the
disadvantages of VPN so starting with
what is a VPN VPN stands for virtual
private Network it's a service that
helps you stay private and secure while
browsing the internet a VPN creates a
secure encrypted connection between your
device and the internet making it
impossible for anyone to intercept your
data and now we'll see how does a VPN
works so to understand how our VPN Works
let's imagine and let's imagine a tunnel
that connects your device to the
internet and all your data passes
through this tunnel ensuring privacy and
security when you use a VPN it encrypts
all your data on your device before
sending it through the tunnel to the
internet this encryption ensures that
even if someone intercepts your data
they won't be able to decipher it your
data is encrypted and your IP address is
hidden making it difficult for any to
trace your online activities the
encryption tunnel created by a VPN
protects your data from hackers cyber
criminals and even your internet service
provider it works by scrambling your
data into an unreadable code that can
only be decrypted by your device and the
VPN server when you connect to a website
through a VPN server your connection
appears to come from the server rather
than your device this helps protect your
privacy and prevents websites from
tracking your real location so this is
how a VPN works now moving on uh but
before moving on you could just see this
diagram and you would be very clear how
does this VPN works so here is the VPN
tunnel through which the encrypted data
flows so when the encrypted data flows
from the VPN tunnel even the internet
service provider can't detect your IP
address and this IP address or this
encrypted data that would be converted
into some codes and that would be
detected by the VPN server and that
increases the privacy and then you to
access the internet or the website you
want to access so we are done with how
VPN works now we'll see some types of
VPN so there are two main types of VPN
the first one is Remote Access VPN and
the second is site to site VPN so remote
access vpns allow individuals to
securely connect to a private Network
while side to side vpns they are used by
businesses to connect multiple locations
and vpns use different encryption
protocols to ensure the security of your
connection and here we have openvpn that
is an example and is an open source
protocol known for its strong security
features it's important to choose a VPN
provider that uses reliable encryption
protocols to safeguard your data now
we'll see why we use VPN or why you need
a VPN now that we have understood how a
VPN Works let's talk about why we need
one so first and foremost a VPN offers
privacy by encrypting your data and
routing it through secure servers a VPN
Shields or online activities from your
internet service provider that is ISP
government agencies or hackers it keeps
your personal information such as
browsing history passwords and credit
card details away from trying guys and
the next feature is anonymity it's an
another significant advantage of using a
VPN when you connect to the internet
through a VPN it masks your original IP
address and assign your different one
this makes it difficult for anyone to
track your online activities back to
your real location or identity the next
feature we have is security it's a top
priority when using a VPN by encrypting
your data a VPN ensures that it remains
confidential and secure during
transmission this is particularly
crucial when using public Wi-Fi networks
which are often vulnerable to cyber
attacks a VPN adds an extra layer of
protection safeguarding your sensitive
information from potential hackers
lurking on the same network now move
into another feature that is bypass
filters and unlock websites so this is
one of the key features of a VPN and its
ability to pass that is bypass filters
and unlock websites in certain scenarios
websites may be restricted or blocked by
organizations schools or governments
with a VPN you can bypass these
restrictions and gain access to the
content you desire whether it's social
networking sites streaming platforms or
any other blogged content of you can
allows you to enjoy internet Freedom the
next we have is seasonal restrictions so
Regional restrictions can also be
overcome with a VPN some online services
and websites are available only to
specific regions or countries by
connecting to a VPN server in the
desired location you can change your IP
address and appear as if you are
accessing the internet from that region
this enables you to access jio blocked
content and take advantage of exclusive
offers or services and now the next
feature is changing your IP address so
using a VPN also allows you to change
your IP address which enhances your
online privacy and security your ISP can
track your online activities and collect
data on your browsing habits however
when you use a VPN your real IP address
is hidden making it difficult for anyone
including your internet service provider
to monitor your internet usage online
anonymity is a valuable benefit of using
a VPN by masking your IP address and
encrypting your data a VPN helps protect
your identity online websites and online
services won't be able to track your
activities or collect personal
information about you without your
consent while vpns offer numerous
advantages it's important to be aware of
some potential disadvantages so vpns
slow down your internet connection and
it could be sometimes that the Slowdown
new internet connections that is due to
the encryption and re-routing of data
the distance between your device and the
VPN server as well as the server's
capacity can impact your connection
speed another consideration is that vpns
may keep logs of your activities despite
claims of a no logs policy some VPN
providers May store certain data it's
essential to research and choose a
reputable VPN service that prioritizes
user privacy and has transparent
policies regarding data retention next
block VPN users that is limitation on
data usage or speed lastly while there
are free VPN services available they
often have limitations on data usage or
speed for regular and reliable VPN usage
opting for a paid subscription is
recommended premium VPN Services
typically offer better speeds more
server locations and stronger security
features in conclusion a VPN is a
valuable tool for protecting your online
security privacy and anonymity it
encrypts your data master your IP
address and allows you to bypass
restrictions and access bloat content
while there are a few drawbacks to
consider the advantages of using a VPN
far outweigh the potential downsides so
whether you are browsing the internet
using public Wi-Fi or accessing jio
blocked content a VPN is an effective
solution to safeguard your online
identity and keep your data secure with
that we have reached the end of this
tutorial let's take a minute to hear
from our Learners who have experienced
massive success in their careers hi I'm
Philip I'm 61 years old and last year
IOP skill with simply learns postcard
program at cyber security after working
30 years in the IIT sector in various
different profiles I'm happy to tell you
that I was able to clear and pass my
cissp and ccsp certification exams on
the first attempt after taking the
course I must say it was packed with
practical examples it was led by highly
skilled certified instructors for many
companies before the security analysts
and architect on a contract basis but I
needed some stability which I got with
the job I just started with as a cyber
security consultant Hunter first if you
have any questions please feel free to
comment and will have it answered for
you as soon as possible until next time
thank you for watching stay safe keep
learning and get ahead
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign